tras casi un año y medio en prisión
erirán el trabajador humanitario belga
Olivier vanden Castel se está dirigiendo
a Bélgica como un ciudadano libre así lo
ha anunciado el Primer Ministro belga
Alexander de croe banda en castell viajó
ayer a Umán desde ahora mismo viaja
hacia Bélgica donde llegará en las
próximas horas confirmado En un
comunicado que ha participado en la
cooperación entre Irán y Bélgica para un
intercambio de Rehenes según las
autoridades iraníes panten castell ha
salido liberado a cambio de un la
liberación de un ciudadano iraní asola a
sadie un preso en Bélgica por intentar
atentar contra opositores del régimen de
Irán en una manifestación en París en
2018 Bélgica siempre había defendido la
inocencia de Olivia vandem castell que
había sido acusado por las autoridades
iraníes por supuesto espionaje tanto la
familia como las autoridades belgas
habían denunciado que el juicio
contrabande en castella había estado
plagado de irregularidades Irán condenó
a este trabajador humanitario a 40 años
de prisión ya 74 latigazos recientemente
la familia de olivé en castella había
denunciado las condiciones infrahumanas
en las que se encontraba Olive Bank en
castell en la prisión de Irán tras más
de 400 días Olive Band en castell hoy
podrá volver a abrazar a su familia